we're very excited about our next guest
New York Times best-selling author it's
Louise Petty she's best known for her
series of mystery novels that follow
Chief Inspector Armond gamash as he
investigates murders in a fictional
small town that small town called you
know it if you read the books three
Pines and there is a Prime video series
on her work also called three Pines and
it will premiere on Friday here's a
preview
tomorrow we need to get statements from
everybody who was at the curling match
and friends and family true and also we
have to track down our photographer Saul
Petrov any update on the pathology
report I'll be ready first thing in the
morning good oh and a situation room
Asian Nicole perhaps you can help seeing
as you're local yeah sure thing
and now what do we do now
well no murder was ever solved on an
empty stomach
in Penny's new book a world of
Curiosities inspector gamash
investigates mysterious objects found in
a hidden room all while being confronted
with old memories as characters
re-emerge from his past at Louise Penny
joins us now thank you very much for
being here thank you for having me yes
your 18th I know novel I'm a recidivist
wow uh coming up on a 20 year
anniversary uh and you are always asking
a party yeah is that where this is
heading yes yeah we have a cake coming
out here come right back here uh you're
always asked where your ideas come from
and in the acknowledgment section you
talk about it and you have some theories
But ultimately you say it comes down to
a little bit of magic can you talk a
little bit about that magic well I it's
like a pointless painting for me it's
just an idea here a thought here I read
a lot of poetry so it's a couplet there
a conversation and then eventually it
all comes together you'll hope it comes
together
um although my first drafts are
they don't well they're not good they're
not why do you say that because in this
book in particular you have a lot of
characters you have a lot of story lines
you tie it all together very nicely yeah
you did but I wonder what did your first
drafts look like on this book I can't
imagine well it's more like what they
smell like what do you mean it really
smell like something soft and smelly oh
wow okay but so that's you know why I'll
tell you why when I finished the the
first book and then had to write the
second book and I was terrified and I
went to a therapist and the therapist
said something that changed my life not
just as a writer but as a human being
she said the wrong person is writing the
book your critic is writing the book you
need to thank the critic you need to
bless the critic you need to show the
critic of the door and you need to write
with joy with awareness of how lucky you
are with gratitude you don't have to get
it right just throw everything at it be
brave that had to be freeing just it was
freeing because you don't have to get it
right yeah and be brave be brave get it
right on my front by my front door now
it used to be right where I write I have
last words of Sheamus Heaney who said to
his wife on his deathbed only to marry
which means Be not Afraid so when I
write no lead to Mary no lead to Mary Be
not Afraid and when I write I keep
thinking that just be brave be brave but
as a result the first drafts have all
sorts of
crap so that the critic comes in and
that's when the changes in the second
and third and fourth drafts yes I
simplify simplify simplify well it opens
with a murder and you know it's a woman
and her two young children are
implicated we won't say hi how and then
later on we revisit their lives
following the death of murder of their
mother right and I wonder how you say
that this story is ultimately about
forgiveness yeah it's about I'm trying
to figure a lot of people needed to be
forgiven in the story lots of people
thank God really for me yeah
um yeah I mean what a tyranny it is to
carry those resentments around with us
all our lives and then I mean I talk
about the fact that gamash talks about
the fact which happens to come from me
um but these crimes don't happen on the
spur of the moment they happen because
something has some hook some Barb has
gotten stuck there a resentment that
becomes feted and then explodes out
um but for if you're able to forgive you
can Let It Go not necessarily for the
person you're going to forgive yeah but
for yourself you have to it's freeing
what is it like to see this come to life
and TV show oh there's a question
John
the ones famously said that watching his
book be turned into a film was a lot
like watching an oxen turned into
bullion oh we're reading that you're not
happy with all of it
I I struggled I cried I there were
business meetings where I wept I was so
angry I was so upset by what was
happening then it became clear that what
happens in films and TV I didn't realize
this and I should have it was my fault
is also a process so the first drafts
aren't going to be the last drafts
um so they're they got I would say for
me
80 of it right and that is that's
astonishing all right I'll take 80 so
see let's talk about inspector gomesh
because you said you based him on a man
you wanted to marry and I did and you
didn't I did wow a married gamash well I
love love I really do readers are like
that I want to start writing and come up
with them okay well this is a I love
badly when people come to visit where I
live and they realize I have I had no
creativity I just write what I see every
day and my books are Love Letters to
where I live which is Quebec to the
people who are in my life and gamash is
inspired by by my husband so it's it's
extra special to see him brought alive
and particularly by an actor as
astonishing as Alfred Molina I mean it's
just
breathtaking well can't wait to see your
next book about a Morning Show featuring
um
he's the victim and who's the I don't
want to be the victims Gail's a love
interest yes yes yes okay could I be a
love interest yeah just make me dance
yes no glasses
Louise Penny thank you very much a world
of curiosity goes on sale tomorrow